Um, anyway, I got to get a turtleneck. That's the thing.
You guys better believe I'm getting a turn. Like I'm not around too.
I'm getting a turtleneck. I got to get one before it gets warm.
Cause I got to wear this turtleneck because dude, I'm going to look so,
sexy and a turtleneck. It's unreal, dude. I swear to God, you know what?
As a matter of fact, yay, this week, I'm getting a turtleneck dude. This week,
I'm getting a turtleneck and all you haters that think I won't can go kiss my
dude. I'm getting a turtleneck and it's going to come up to my jaw and bro,
it's going to make my mandibular pop out so hard. I swear to God,
you know what I'm gonna do. I'm getting a turtleneck.
But I also guess I gotta get towels because there's going to be chicks around
and I don't want their sweat,
the holes so much that they slip and fall and break their ankles.
Cause then I got a lawsuit, dude,
I'm going to get a turtleneck.
And then I'm going to get a bag of big towels and just pass them
out. When I see chicks and she'll be like, why? Oh, I got it.
Why are you? And then see me about my popping.
Cause also I trim my beard to make it look like, Whoa, bro.
When I do a four or a five on the tremor and my,
my jawline it's like, people are like, yo,
did someone draw that?
So I got now a turtleneck with a four or five trim and I'm going to be walking
around town. Like it's legal dude. I've got a bag.
I'm going to get two bags. I'm gonna get a backpack. And two big Ikea bags of,
of towels. And whenever I see a chick, especially in a skirt,
I got to pass out a towel because I don't want her to break her ankles.
I don't want to do, I don't want to,
I don't want her to slam her tailbone on the conk. I don't want that.
Excuse me. Ma'am sorry. But I've got a turtleneck on. If I wear a turtleneck,
they'll let me in anywhere. Just so you know, just so you know,
they'll let me in anywhere, dude. That's how sexy I look. Oh.
And then this.
Oops, oopsie.
Daisy, can you hear it on audio oopsy? Daisy,
the heavy snake chain comes out halfway through the night.
I got to go get more towels. You understand me, dude? I swear to God, man,
put a turtleneck on my body. See what happens?
Put a turtleneck on my torso and see what happens.
To me.
Putting it on like this and then folding it over.
Whoops, me folding it over like that, putting it on. And then me putting it,
put it on like this,
putting it on like this and me folding over is when a guitar kicks me taking
the. Cause it's not mocked. And just,
and then all of a sudden passing out towels, dude, here you go. Here you go.
And then chicks, Whoa and her. Cause I can't, it's it's a shame too,
because I can't get,
get towels out fast enough because when I'm in crowded places, girls are like,
what the? And they fall and they fall casually. They, they become, you know,
they, they become casualties to my turtleneck game casualties to a turtleneck
game. That's what they become. And it's sad too, man.
But hopefully they were an idea. It's sad as. I'm sorry, sweetheart.
I tried to get over here as quickly as I could to get you a towel.
I know because I've got a turtleneck on,
it was really irresponsible and dangerous. I mean, but I,
and I also have a four or five on my trimmed beard, but it's really sad.
Here's an extra towel before you get up, put it down.
I don't want you to slipping and falling because you're putting gets so bad
because I've got to turtleneck on the run,
hustle away with my Ikea bags,
just making this noise,
running away with my two big Ikea bags and a turtleneck on with a heavy chain
out. Just slap it against my chest, dude. God, how sexy can you be?
I also got to be a, I also got a backwards hat. I don't call it a hat.
I call it a backwards hat. I got a backwards hat.
I got a hat in Florida once and I wore it and it was so sexy and everyone was
like. You're so what's going on. You do things to me in this hat.
I had to get some towels and then I left the hat on the plane and then a few
months went by. I'm more into the hat.
And then I was in Irvine today and I got an LA hat. So I'm I'm about to start.
man. It's too bad. A turtleneck with a, uh,
hat doesn't look good cause it doesn't because if it did,
they would call me population control. That's legit.
What they will call me because people would be slipping and falling and breaking
their necks. Anyway, dude, I don't mean to brag,
but I'm extremely sexy in a turtleneck and a heavy chain peeking out.
And then also just with, I would have cool pants on too
little in then, then them,
he has a turtleneck and also a heavy sneaker chain that sometimes he takes out
halfway through the night,
but also he's got two heavy Ikea bags with dozens of towels in them
just in case women get so wet while looking at him, noticing his,
his five, his number five razor shaped beard and,
and get so wet. And then the wet goes down their legs.
If they're wearing a skirt and then they slip and hurt their tailbone,
that's when the Leah would come up and hand them a towel out of his Ikea back
and hope for the best. As he ran away,
giving out towels to women that saw him.
Wow,
well we started with some real poignant on this podcast and then turned into
some absolute ridiculous, but I told you it's a silly goose time, dude.
It's a silly goose time, dude. It's a silly goose time man,
and life rips, man.
Just remember even when celebrities die and ideas fade life,
you got to remember that, dude,
life continues to rip and it continues to rip and it continues to rip and it
continues to rip dude, I'm a preacher.
Sure.
So go get your life rips merge. And you know,
I'm trying to make a dollar do it and it does whatever, bro. It don't worry.
Don't get one man. It's an idea. Uh,
Knows my schedule. You at coffee bean.
I have that shirt in my car and I'm headed there.
And then he writes me one at one 49 and then at one 52. Whoa, Holy.
It's closed forever. That's crazy. And then he writes,
I think maybe you're recording. So see ya. He knows it. He knows my business.
That's awesome, dude. This is the one dude. One fire just sent me this one,
this turtleneck dude. You know what I need to do? Wow. That's a good one. St.
Laurent cable roll neck knit. Oh it's only three 65. Oh wow. It's sold out.
Great. Can't get it. Yes, dude.
I saw turtleneck the other day at a place and it was so popping and it was
$3,000 and I was like, are you kidding me? Shore bags, but you're kidding me.
I was like, sure. Of course bank account slogan. But you're kidding me.
I was like, sure, God opened the windows to my house so the cash can breathe.
But 10 may, I was like, sure, I've got stacks. And if I lay down,
it looks like I've got three in my pants, but still, Hey Ken.
Come on, dude.
It was three K and I'm like pass, but also guess what? Wish I got it.
Cause no did Leon's ah,
no deadly aunts dude.
I'm getting a black turtleneck and y'all could go yourself for real and put that
on my tombstone when I die for real.
And I know someone's going to Photoshop this, whatever do it. But when I die,
put this on my tombstone,
I'm getting a black turtleneck and y'all can go yourself
for real. I'm serious. Oh dude, I can't wait to get up.
I'll wear shorts with it. You. Um,
yeah. So I'm going to get a look at these turtle necks, bro.
You know what I need to do?
I need to be one of those hookers on Instagram and be like,
here's my here's my gift list. And just have one thing on it. A dope.
Three K turtleneck and some rich,
either old housewife lady or some old fan is going to get me one dude and then
send it to my PO box and I'll rock that, dude.
I need to get one of those things.
And models have that thing. Here's my gift list. My lift, my gift list.
You're a straight-up dude. Just blow. How about that?
He looked at what's on it. A bag. Oh yeah.
Why don't girls love to keep things in things,
Mr. Porter, they got turtlenecks. Who's that? I don't know,
but turtlenecks amazing.
The authorities seem to write off that debt to youthful indiscretion making it
up, but still getting it.
Ooh, Brown turtleneck looks nice. Ralph Lauren, Ralph Lauren,
Ralph Lauren. I'm gonna make it more rough. Lauren. Purple label.
Need it. Oh wow.
I'm going to be the only in summer wearing a turtleneck.
I don't like those puffy ones. God, you look like a.
When you wear those puffy ones, the puffy necks. Wow. You look like a.
Like what is this? 1996. And your Lance bass.
Oh wow. Look at this one logo. And now look at this one. Jesus Christ.
We get bill Cosby on a warm day. Um,
can't wait to get a turn light and your. You're not gonna know what hit you.
That's how you know I'll I'll know that chicks are feeling me with my turtle
neck, but there'll be like, Hey, pass out.
It did. I'm going to bring little towels around for real. Like I got to start.
I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to straight up do that at the laugh factory one night.
Maybe Wednesday night. Yeah. That's what I'm gonna do.
All right. That's it. Twitter questions NAF. it.
Should we wrap.